my dad worked his ass off and when he  died  he did good  my mom had to sell everything  and so i'm like okay that didn't work  but he was considered successful the  middle class successful briefcase good  job professional people respected him  saved his money had life insurance house  was paid for everything by the book  and she was unloading stuff the next  week because she was terrified and so  from the age of 10 to like  16 17 years old we were just scared dude  clipping coupons  buying everything on sale  single mother everywhere she goes she  knows they're gonna rip her off the  plumber the roofer the car dealer  everybody's gonna rip her off right so  she thought save your money save for a  rainy day yeah you know penny saved is  right a penny earned it's not it's a  penny yeah right it's a penny yeah i  mean it's a penny dude yeah you won't  even pick a penny up today